I'll be traveling next month and don't want to miss my coffee in about time.
It gets to be a lot of stuff to travel with.
My thought is to add boiling water to the grounds at night and let it set overnight to
straight and use in the morning, thoughts, tips, or tricks.
Okay, so, go back to the course, let me go on the course really quick and see what
matter. Do I have it? Maybe it's on this page video there, it looks like that.
Okay, so this page, I'm going to share my screen with you real quick.
Okay, so this is the, on the membership site. So on the membership site, this is the page entitled
Detoxification Details. I have to see if this is a, oh, I guess it's not working.
So we get YouTube that takes down videos of ours that literally every week, such a fight
with the world these days. So this, you already know how to do coffee animals. You're an expert
at how to do coffee animals. However, I created an easy PC way to do coffee animals right
here. This works really good if you're out and about. So this first step, prepare coffee
is what you're asking about. So literally when you're out and when you're, when you're traveling,
just go get some organic coffee and make some coffee in the morning and let it cool or add
a little bit of water and do the easy peasy way where you're standing in the shower doing
the coffee animal. So just keep it really simple as I wrote here. Just keep it really simple.
Don't stress. You're doing a coffee animal to stimulate your parasympathetics. If you're
stressing about doing a coffee animal, you're, you're, you're defeating the whole purpose
of doing a coffee animal. You're stimulating your sympathetic to try to stimulate your
parasympathetics. So just, just do it super easy. If you don't have to go buy a cup of coffee
at a coffee shop, or if you have a coffee maker at wherever you're traveling, just make
some coffee. You know, it doesn't have to be done the perfect way. So just do it, just do
it that way. That would the way I would do it. And, and make your coffee and then do a
steady coffee in a bit of the shower just to make it easy on your traveling.